they'll press author of spin this when
you hear Bill O'Reilly saying his
program you're entering a no-spin zone
what's your reaction my reaction is
that's baloney or pure spin I mean he's
thinning the fact that he doesn't spin
which I don't think anybody takes
seriously or should why shouldn't they
take it seriously isn't he being serious
about it no I think if you in fact I've
got lots of examples in my book first of
all right but the premise of the book is
that everybody spends and especially
people in the media spin and for someone
to say that I am different than anybody
else that everybody else bins but I tell
the absolute truth is just not credible
it's not believable it's a it's an act
and it's a successful act by the way his
show is very successful but if you
listen to the top of his show he will
say things like for example is Al Gore
you know really has Al Gore really grown
a beard because he knows he doesn't have
a chance in 2004 and he's already giving
up yeah you're entering the spin free
zone well he's already given this been
sort of proven the case it's a shtick
that's a successful stick but now during
this interview when can we when should
we what should be the tip-off that
you're spinning us when my lips are
moving that's kind of what I say about
politicians we always used to say how
can you tell when a politician is lying
and his lips are moving I think today we
would say how do you tell when almost
anybody is spinning which again the
point I'd like to try to make in the
book is we hear about so much about
political spin and that's true and
that's sort of the the place where you
find the most spin in life is in
politics politicians can hardly talk
without spinning but what I found out
once I get into looking into spin is
that everybody spends it is universal
preachers spin and salesmen spin
advertising as all his pure spin doctors
been their patients lawyers spin judges
and we spent each other in our daily
lives who have you ever met in your life
or watching your life
the one that I think comes the closest
to it and I talked about him in the book
because I admired now a great deal is
Senator John McCain I traveled with
McCain during the last presidential
campaign not the whole campaign but I
spent a few days with him in New
Hampshire and I was just stunned to see
how accessible he made himself
for example the straight talk expressed
which could be called the no-spin
Express right and McCain would come walk
on the bus sit down there be a gaggle of
reporters around him chosen each day or
rotated in and out by his staff and
McCain would just sit down and basically
say fire away
there was no opening statement there was
no opening spin he would take any
questions he never ducked one question
and he was a prisoner on that bus we
were going that day to his last town
meeting which was Peterborough New
Hampshire it was maybe an hour and 15
minutes away so you know he couldn't run
to the back of the bus he couldn't run
off the bus
I don't know any other politician in
this country who is capable of doing
that
or who would consider doing that why
didn't he win then alas because then
works and I think sometimes that John
McCain's straight talk got him into
trouble if I can and push the bush
campaign were very adept at spinning in
fact they were able to spin the reason
that McCain got such good press was
because all the reporters you know like
liked him
personally and didn't like George Bush
personally so they turned it against the
media when in fact he got such good
press because he was so good and he was
so honest and he was so forthright and
he any-any gave out a lot of good
material how many years have you now
work for CNN five and a half came in
February 1996 as co-host of crossfire go
back to when it all started who called
you who called you first at CNN and why
oh you mean how crossfire yeah that's
you how did you get there
well I was doing radio and television in
California at two stations in Southern
California
first kabc-tv and then Casey Opie TV and
I always wanted to take a shot at the at
the national level tried several times
failed they didn't want anything to do
with anybody in California who didn't
ABC didn't CNN at that time didn't I
tried you know various things I was
working at the ABC station in LA for
example I wanted to sit in I asked who I
could sit in on a brinkley Roundtable
maybe you know once a year just as a
voice from outside the Beltway nobody
was ever interested so then fast forward
to 1996 I read in the Los Angeles Times
of Michael Kinsley he had left crossfire
and I thought well maybe one more stab
so I CNN didn't call me I called CNN I
called Rick Davis's executive producer
of crossfire and I said look I do TV
I've done TV for 10 12 years I'm good at
it I know as much as all those guys to
give me a shot try somebody outside the
Beltway and he I was lucky because he
had seen me debating Pat Buchanan once
at a convention somewhere in Los Angeles
actually and so he remembered that and
he said yeah I'll give you a shot so
I'll call you never called so I was
coming back here a friend of I was being
sworn as is in his ambassador and I
called Davis again and said I'm coming
to Washington on my own nickel I'll be
in town how about that shot you promised
me and he said what could he say I think
you know I was here so he said okay
we'll do it
one to three days I think and so I came
in I got in the rotation up against some
pretty heavyweight contenders and got
the job
what happened next how do you know you
mean well at what point did you know you
were gonna get this job well it was it
was a funny process like when I came in
I did three days with Bob Novak at the
time Novak and Sununu were the co-hosts
so I did three days with Bob Novak I
went back to Los Angeles you're gonna
think I'm a pest here but I called
Brooke Davis again I'm not a pest I'm
persistent and I said gee I had a lot of
fun with Bob Novak and I think I held my
own give me a shot at Sunna No so he
said okay so I came back again and I did
a couple of days by the way these are
not screen tests I mean these are not
like auditions in a closed room
somewhere I mean this these were live on
the air audition so I mean he'd make her
break yourself right away so I was on
for two two days with John Sununu and I
thought that went okay and I will
interact in California and this time for
the first time Rick Davis called me and
he said we like to get you to come back
for a third time third test and I said
well what's going on and he said well
there's a short list and you've made the
short list and we want to take another
look at you so I came back a third time
and then I got a call from him maybe a
week later in fact it was on a Wednesday
I recall I was to start on Monday
full-time the following Monday I was
democratic chair in addition during
radio and TV as a volunteer I was a
democratic chairman of California at the
time I had to quit my job move to
Washington get here and start a full
time job at CNN the following Monday
when you go into a job like that how
long were you guaranteed to have a job
at the time I didn't have a contract at
all but I was given the job and then I
negotiated contract the first first
contract was for two years and the
second was for three years and if you're
doing the math I'm ready to sign another
one how do they know specifically how do
they know you're doing a good job
well I think you'd have to ask them that
I mean a zero you know I'm not gonna but
I was there they do the Q ratings and
all that kind of stuff too I think that
I would think that there'd be tooth
- things are looking at one is that how
I'm performing on the air I mean again
I've never had this conversation with
them but they've got to know I do my
homework they have to know I know my
facts and they have to know I can hold
my own against Pat Buchanan and Mary
Matalin Bob Novak Johnson uno Tucker
Carlson not to mention the guests and
then there are ratings we got ratings
every day unlike radio where you wait
like three months to know how you're
doing television every the next day we
know how well we did the night before so
I haven't destroyed the ratings of the
show what time of day the next day do
you know what the ratings are we know
about four o'clock in the afternoon what
we did the night before and how close do
they break it down within that half hour
that you're on 15 minutes and 15 minutes
so for example if we follow money line
or we follow Wolf Blitzer whatever we
follow we can tell right away what they
had at 7:30 and what we hold onto at
7:30 plus what we add we can also tell
us 7:45 how many people we have picked
up or lost in that second half of the
show and then we can tell at 8 o'clock
when we go off the air how many people
are left and how many people we hand on
to the next show it's it's amazing and
it's all done with Nielsen boxes and
frankly I don't I never believed it's
that accurate but everybody uses the
same system so everybody believes it now
can you tell I mean you're sitting there
every night and hearing people you say
to yourself this person is just spinning
us to death can you tell from the
ratings when somebody is spending here
that people tune out or the vice versa
that they tune they like it yes and yes
and no sometimes I think it's not so
much that they're spinning it's just
sometimes you get a guest who's really
deadly dull I mean no matter how how
well they've been screened and we talk
to them ahead of time you know the staff
pre-interviews them and they give us a
sense this guy's
like a real fireball you know he's he's
really saying some really strong stuff
he's gonna be a great guest but they get
on camera and they just freeze and and
they're and you just think oh no you
know you can just like hear the clickers
all over the country going off and yet
some time to tell you honestly and it
hasn't been that long ago that a show
that Tucker Carlson and I thought was
deadly dull and we got one of the
highest ratings that we've had in months
so I think I think all of us believe
that the guests make the show not the
co-hosts by the way we get really good
guest that's what people and
particularly well-known guests as people
are clicking through a whole menu of
stuff that's available on television
these days and there's so many choices
so they click click click they see
somebody you know I mean they see Tom
Daschle right they'll stop or they'll
see Dick Armey
you know they'll stop never see a Mary
Matalin you know they'll stop as she
said she's a guest so I think the guests
make the show but sometimes even a bad
guest and get a good rating you Republic
big you're on the Republicans or
Democrats been the most I don't think
there's any difference I think they all
spend they're all good at it and as I as
I point out in the book I think though
among the Presidents Bill Clinton gets
the prize master spinner just wonderful
to behold I mean just brilliant to watch
him and spit himself out of situation
after situation after situation and yet
III have to admit and I give him credit
the Bush White House is as keeping up
with the Clinton White House I believe
so far they're they're very very good
they're very adept Karl Rove Karen
Hughes during the campaign and in the
White House I think they have been
masters of the art when did you get the
idea for this book remember the first
moment yeah actually I liked like many
ideas it came to me in the shower
Eureka went went during the spin room
for a while we started during the
during the last turn the last
presidential campaign
CNN needed to do they knew they needed
needed to do something different
late night because all the coverage was
kind of looking like it always had and
so they asked Tucker Carlson and me to
do this special show late night called
the spin room and I started out being an
hour and basic we just got people on to
spin how the campaign's were going
people from the campaign's reporters to
talk about the spin they were hearing in
the campaign's and I so I just got drew
fascinated with that whole concept of
spin and thought having thought about a
lot of different books and started one
block or started another book it
suddenly occurred to me that was Isis
right in front of me was the book that I
should write I should write a book about
spin because everyone was talking about
spin but nobody was really explaining
what it is who spins and who doesn't is
it good is it bad what's the difference
between a spin and a lie you know what's
the origin of this word spin so I
thought it would be really fun really
timely we were doing a show on spin and
even though by the time I had finished
writing the spin room was canceled spin
lives even if the spin room did not so
one day during the middle that while we
were doing the show is in the shower
think about it came to me write a book
about spin and thought of the title spin
this and here we are what you do though
how'd you miss your first book it isn't
he so where did you start I started by I
start I called my agent now what's an
agent agent is a guy who who represents
you in making a contract a lawyer
usually represents you and making your
contract and can also take a product and
sell it to for example I have a
television agent he does that represents
me and my negotiations with CNN he's
also very good book agent how is he live
here in Washington what is his name his
name is the Bob Barnett and married to
married to Rita braver of CBS News and
Bob's
the best in the business did in during
the debate practice he was for I think
now for the last three presidential
campaigns he has filled in in the mock
debates for the Democratic candidate
he's played the opponent I think the
first time the Bill Clinton ran he
played George Bush you know the second
time he played Bob Dole and this time
for Al Gore I believe he played w so
he's very very good very sharp having
represented Bill Clinton and and the
first lady president and the first lady
with their books and since I'm kind of
an equal opportunity offender in the
book and I point out that the president
first lady's been as well as other
Democrats as well as the Republicans I
hope I'm not talking out of school here
he thought it was not a product that he
could properly represent so um he
suggested another good friend of mine
and his fella by name of Ron Goldfarb
who was also excellent very very good
very well respected in the industry and
I called Ron and told him I had an idea
and he said put together a little
proposal he even suggested kind of what
I might put the proposal I put a
proposal together gave it to him
he liked it changed it a little bit but
finally got a product that he really
liked he took it to New York there were
three publishers who were interested and
they had a little auction and one of
them said okay we'll publish it and we'd
like to get it out by Christmas which
meant and I promised them by the way in
the proposal that I could write it fast
and I could write it in three months so
I signed a contract and turned it in a
week early and when was the week he
turned it in I turned it in the last
week of August was due September 1 and
what about the experience of writing the
book I know from talking to you before
on the shows and all you are a big
reader what I found for one thing is I
haven't read as many books this year as
I usually do because I had to take up a
lot of my time what one of the reasons I
really wanted to start
with with spin was as a my first book
because as I mentioned was to hop ago
certainly Familia was a topic I was
living but I also wanted to make sure I
because there a lot of other books
inside of me I wanted to make sure I had
the discipline to really write a book
and so I once I had the contract I just
set myself to it I mean I wrote every
spare time mornings all morning except
two mornings a week I write a column I
continue to do that but three mornings a
week I wrote at least one day a weekend
I wrote the entire half a day and then I
come home from doing crossfire or spin
room and I'd work and write until maybe
2:00 2:30 in the morning and just banged
it out easier or harder than you thought
harder actually harder because when
you're working with something I've
written a lot of magazine articles
written a lot of op eds
but there you can get your hand around
those easily when you're writing forget
how many words this is but let's say 200
thousand words or something like that
you know I found there has to be a
continuity of thought and I sometimes
lost and have to go back and see what I
made that point or not made that point
and it to get you know it skipped the
hit the flow of the book and and after
you get into it I mean it's it becomes a
you become a prisoner of that word
processor so sometimes I was really
chafing you know at the discipline time
imposed on myself but it's a great
satisfaction to get it done and then to
see the first proofs and then to see the
galleys and then to see a finished book
I mean it's pretty exciting word is the
word spin come from spin a couple of
origins of spin the first is which I
find personally appealing and amusing is
it comes from the old spinning wheel and
weaving I say that because my wife is a
is a weaver so she she does this she
doesn't spin her own yarn and anymore
buys the wool but she's this Weaver and
you can see if you if you pull and
stretch a piece of yarn you can pull and
stretch a tail or a story and so the
first is like the old sea captain who
would spin a yarn that's really kind of
where it comes from the use of that word
the second is from sports baseball throw
a curve you put a spin on the ball on
billiards you put a certain backspin
maybe on the ball or even on the como on
the golf course if you're good enough
I'm not you can put a backspin on you're
on the ball hitting the green so it
doesn't roll off the other side of the
green so um both both both origins of it
and you can see also with if you can put
a spin on the ball you can put a spin on
your word still which i think is is
really what what spin is it's just sort
of it's not the truth it's not a lie
it's somewhere in between it's just
adjusting the truth if you will or
bending the truth to make a point to
make things look better than they are or
to make you look better than you are or
to cover your button get out of a
difficult situation is there more
spinning today than there has been in
our history I don't think so I think we
just have given it a name today you know
I I in the book I had a lot of fun going
back in in history and and pointing out
some of the well I think of a classic
spin starting with the Garden of Eden
where everything else gets started right
and and Adam and Eve and and the serpent
spinning Eve that there's this wonderful
tree and you eat this root and you'll be
like God you'll know everything you know
but from evil which was which is really
certainly not the truth and then and
when when God said to Adam what have you
done you know Adam right away said she
made me do it
a spin that comes down through time of
course husbands and boyfriends do the
same play but on the girlfriend or the
wife but you can you can go through
politics and through history
I think there are many examples I just
think today and Brian I don't know
exactly when it started but the first
time that I heard of it is maybe maybe
six or eight years ago when campaigns
first started using the word spin doctor
spin room after a debate for example
everybody gathers in this hall and and
the candidates come in and all their
handlers come in and all their friends
come in why to spin the reporters don't
know how well they've done and they call
it the spin room you mentioned in your
book that you used to be a seminarian
indeed where was that it was on the East
Coast the United States first of all I
joined an order called the Oblates of
st. Francis DeSales who taught my high
school so lazy Anna High School in
Wilmington Delaware and they were
located up and down the East Coast and I
did my I did some practice teaching in
Philadelphia got my college degree at
the University of Niagara all as a
seminarian and then I was sent to Europe
to study theology at the University of
Freiburg in Switzerland why did you get
into this why I wanted everybody's
thinking at that time what they're gonna
do with their life I was really
attracted to public service for a year
it's when I graduated from high school I
heard you first 1958 and at first I
thought about studying law because I I
was thinking the pro bono kind of lawyer
helping people and I actually applied
for law school and and I was I was
attracted to the work that these men did
at the school their life of service and
what combination of public service and
in God's service if you will so I
thought this would be the right career
for me and I realized definitely nine
years but once I was that far
long that I would would have come out as
a priest his job was to teach high
school and as much as I liked teaching I
wanted to do more with my life than the
a high school teacher I wanted to be
more involved in community affairs I
wasn't sure exactly what but I know I
wanted to kind of a bigger arena than
that so I left the seminary in 67 what
was the family situation like your
mother your father brothers sisters all
of the above
right my parents were both living then
my mother died later in 67 at that time
I had a brother a sister I grew up with
a brother and a sister
they're both younger than me but then
after I was in the seminary my parents
had two more children so they're like a
second family
then my mother died and my father
remarried and he and his wife have still
another son so I have two brothers two
sisters and a half-brother what'd your
father do he was a self-employed small
businessman in Delaware City Delaware
where I grew up a little town on the
Delaware River south of Wilmington when
he came out of the service his father
had a guest station Atlantic gas station
and he gave my father a piece of
property right down the street it's a
pretty brave thing to do knowing that my
father was going to do and did he built
with his own hand built his own service
station and he ran an operated gas
station service station for the rest of
his life
I mean why he's still alive but I mean I
told until he sold it how about your mom
she was a housewife and raised us kids
and helped my father run the business
she took care of all the books but you
know she didn't have any job outside of
that and she wasn't paid for that she
just made sure the business succeeded by
getting the bills out at the end of the
month you know so the people would pay
the bills so we could pay our bills were
they surprised when you became a
seminarian oh yeah yeah they had no idea
I wasn't that big much of a help raised
but they didn't expect me to they're
very pleased who raised a Catholic
family very observant Catholic family
but nobody and I was the first kid in my
family to go to college and so let alone
go into seminary or become a priest
they're pleased and I'm sure I know
disappointed when I left was there ever
a time when you thought the church was
spinning you many times I I talk in the
book about religion as an arena of
spinned
and you have to be careful because you
know you say things about religion and
people automatically kind of brand you
as a heretic or as a there's an atheist
but I mean and the spin that I have the
hardest I mean if you will all of
religion is either based on a
fundamental truth or an outrageous spin
which is that this is the this is the
veil of Tears and and yeah this is a
tough life but we just kind of get
through it because the good times are
ahead of us and so we suffer and we
accept suffering now and we accept pain
and we accept illness and misfortune
knowing that by doing so we're going to
earn an eternity of a bliss now that's
kept a lot of people going for a long
time and it's either to say it's either
true or or probably the worse or best
spin ever but inside of religion the
thing that I find the hardest to deal
with is is pain pain and suffering and
and and really bad things happening to
good people and you know I always hear
it at so many services where somebody
young and somebody in the middle of
their career or a child even is killed
and killed in some accident and and the
preacher says well you know he's better
off because he's up in heaven you know
with all of his friends and
and I just I don't buy it I buy it I
find I find it hard to accept a God who
would send a commercial airliner into
the World Trade Center buildings and
kill 6000 people you know and to just
say well they're all better off well if
I had the answers I'd be Pope maybe but
all I'm saying is it's a spin that works
I'll tell you at us work it makes people
feel better people do like that
consolation they like that assurance
that this is all part of God's plan but
I think there's got to be something more
what in your own mind created this
attitude that you didn't believe it
anymore I I guess I would say it's my
idea of of God is not a God who would
impose cruelty on people that he loves
so it's a different perception of God
and then when I hear people say that
this this is part of God's plan I wonder
what kind do they believe in how old
were you when this happened it was an
evolving process probably during my
seminary days you know who says Warner
Seth Warner it's a wonderful wonderful
friend I mention him in the book when I
was in the seminary I went to as I
mentioned what was sent to Freiburg
Switzerland to study theology and one
day a woman next door knocked on the
door and asked me if there was anybody
there who could help her translate a
letter because she had an apartment and
she had a letter from a couple in
California we were thinking of coming to
Switzerland for sabbatical and they were
from Malibu California I had growing up
in Delaware barely heard of California
I'd never heard which became one of my
favorite places in life so I said I'll
do it for you and it turned out the Seth
and Marjorie Warner who were from Malibu
was a professor at Santa Monica City
College of history philosophy and they
came and I met them when they arrived
there was several letters that I ended
up translating you don't talk about how
BIG's the apartment how many rooms of
the bathrooms where's the nearest bus
stop all this kind of stuff that a
daughter was in school where could she
go to school and they took the apartment
and they came and we became fast and
wonderful friends and when I was leaving
the seminary they suggested unusual for
anybody from California why don't you
come to California and gave me a list of
schools that I might where I might get a
job teaching school I wrote letters and
actually got a job through the mail
teaching school and in California and
then they've just been they were fast
fast friends or wonderful wonderful
people and sets EFT
he died about five years ago by the way
it was great fun to be around he was
great reader and he always would save
things from the nation or a new republic
or the latest book he was reading the
uses of the past a herbert viola Muller
was one of his favorite books and he
would read passages to me and I learned
so much from him and grew so much I
think he's great at him was giving him
your introduction to liberalism well he
was a but he was a strong liberal and I
find that well that's tough you know I
always III think of a of a liberal as
someone with an open mind and open heart
and open hands somebody who welcomes
change as opposed to a conservative who
likes to keep things the way they are
someone who really believes in people
and and and that government has a role
and government's role is really to be
helping those that but don't yet share
in the fullness of the American Dream
helping those who really need to need a
helping hand
maybe not for their entire life but at
least to give them a lift up and I was
certainly that was my inclination but I
would say you know Seth convinced me
that that was the right way and that was
the that was that was the path and so I
spent a lot of time with him in
California and he helped me helped me a
great deal
Marjorie is still alive lives in Carmel
and and Seth died about five years ago
how did you become chairman of the
Democratic Party in California it was a
fluke
I didn't that's one time when I didn't
sink the job the job came after me bill
angelitos who is now the state treasurer
of California called me this is a job
that lasts two years and it rotates
north and south so the chair has to be
from Southern California and then moves
up to Northern California phil was in
Northern California he wanted to run for
re-election but that the committee said
no we refused to change the rules it's
got to be somebody from the south so
Phil called me out of the blue and said
we need it's a volunteer job didn't pay
a dime we need somebody in the south who
would agree to be chair of the
Democratic Party would you run and I
thought about it and it was this was 93
Barbara Boxer had just been elected
Senator Dianne Feinstein had just been
elected senator and Bill Clinton had
just been elected president and I
thought it might be a good time to be
chairman of the Democratic Party in
California for two years so I ran
against a fella by the name of Steve
Barr I won and served until I quit to
come back for crossfire did you ever
spend during the time you were where
they were and did you ever feel bad
about it did you ever hear yourself
saying things you said oh that's just so
oh oh yeah yeah yes to both questions
sure I I would spend and yes sometimes I
would feel I can't believe I got away
with that I mean the classic spin is
when you lose an election and you hear
this all the time you lose an election
but you spin why you really it was so
good as winning you did so well
as good as winning and and I can
remember when we might have a special
election and we go down and we really
bust our butt and spend a lot of money
and walk all these precincts and yet
lose and then I would come out with
something like yeah well but the
important thing is not who won or lost
the important thing is that we got you
know 78 percent of the Latino vote and
we got 90 percent of the
african-american vote and that proves
that we got our message across and that
we're the party of the people or
something like that which is really
spent I mean is bunk I mean the fact is
the only thing that counts it's really
winning the election but it sort of goes
with the territory
why can't you just say we lost one yeah
you could and it would be you could it's
just the tradition there's so much to
put the best possible you know to to
spin it the tradition is always and the
temptation is to to make it sound as
good as possible so you don't disappoint
you know you kind of maybe want the
people who work so hard in the campaign
you don't want to let them down but I
must say I think would be much more most
refreshing to do it just somebody say
the better I lost we ran a lousy
campaign I lost with the country that
only has half its registered or half its
adult members voting how much of it is
it caused by spinning people are cynical
about the politician I don't know I
don't know whether I could put a number
on it but certainly I think the number
one factor I believe is the money in
politics I think the number one thing
that turns people off is they don't feel
they have access to the to the
decision-making or the decision makers
because no matter what lip service is
giving to given to listening to people
but the only ones that really have the
candidates here or the campaign managers
here are those write the big checks and
it's true of both parties and that's why
I've always supported campaign finance
reform but after that I'd say would
certainly comment I discussed with
the politicians that they that they see
that's why I think John McCain did so
well in the primaries and I went around
to those town meetings and watched
people I think they walked they might
have walked in a cynic but they walked
away a believer because they saw
somebody who was real and it wasn't
trying to spin it was obviously wasn't
trying to spin so to your question I
think that the spinning does turn people
off I think they feel all politicians
lie or polity or spin or all sound the
same and you can't believe any of them
so you know why follow them why listen
to them ultimately why vote for them sad
I can't let the hour go by without
asking you about Jen Singh
and your little anecdote about York
buying ginseng and I want to know why
you put that in the book I put it does
the powder cover up the you never
thought he might ask you how to cover up
the blushing blame ginseng I'll put it
in context I I was talking about
advertising as the the realm of spin I
mean that's retail advertising or
wholesale advertising I mean they people
spin these products and gullible as we
are we believe these products you know
buy this vacuum cleaner it'll make
vacuuming fun you know it won't
still drudgery but we somehow believe it
or about this car you know whatever it
is okay so I was actually sitting on the
set with Pat Buchanan one day and of
these during a commercial break and I
saw this not one time but maybe the
tenth time it finally started to sink in
and I see this ad on the air for this
product called jinsana and NS showed all
these young people and they're playing
volleyball or whatever and they're
running around and they're they're so
attractive and that maybe I was feeling
pretty badly battered by Pat Buchanan
that day or a little tired or something
and I so I thought mm-hmm that might and
they're supposed to give you so much
more Pepin so much
our energy make you so much younger so I
actually went down to the CVS at the
corner seventh in Pennsylvania the next
day and I bought myself some jinsana and
you're supposed to I think take two a
day or whatever it was and I was popping
it for about a year and my my cousin on
the eastern Eastern Shore Murray Bend
ler I was visiting with her one day and
I asked her about this dance and she
said as I say in the book it's about as
good as taking nothing
she's very laconic Murray she doesn't
not this big glob said there's a
paragraph that I said what do you mean
and she said what I said what'd you say
again she said it's about as good as
taking nothing yeah and so it was all
just hype so it's just not real or was
it good one of you has a good Democrat a
good liberal wouldn't you wouldn't you
want the government put a label on that
so this is a bunch of bunk
you know it's yes with all those vitamin
supplements all those diet supplements
and all that stuff it's so much of
medicine is in the mind anyhow and I
think for some people it may work I
guess it works for me for a year yeah
I'd rather see a warning on there saying
this is and I think I think there are
warnings on some products that this is
not approved by the CDC or the FDA and
so take at your own risk or kind of
whatever you know all those products go
back to Crossfire's down there with pat
buchanan or bob novak or tucker carlson
and you ever find yourself at a break
saying you know i really don't want to
come back and defend my side I'm on your
side this case I mean you are you there
to take aside whether you believe it or
not no I would never say anything on
television I didn't believe never never
no I I wouldn't end I think that's
important I think it's important because
I think people have to trust us whether
we're coming from the right or from the
left and
I mean I know I don't want to become
like those politicians I was just
talking about that you you really never
know so then sometimes people will come
up to me and say you know I don't agree
with you all the time but that's okay
because I know you've just got to do
that for ratings right you've got you
can't believe all that stuff you stay on
there right and I say guess what I hate
to tell you but I really do the same of
Pat Buchanan it's the same with Bob Nova
the most that we will do is sometimes if
both of us do agree we'll tell people up
front you know this is a topic with both
of us agree on but somebody's got to
play the devil's advocate tonight so
I'll play the devil's advocate so we
will you know I can ask tough questions
but I tell people up front it's not
where I'm coming from five years now
what is CNN five five five and a half
right during that time MSNBC Fox News
come along you're in real competition
with two other operations what's changed
inside CNN since you've been there well
a couple of things have changed one is
we're looking over our shoulder well we
didn't have to before I mean when CNN
started had the cable world to itself
cable news world certainly to itself
different world today because of MSNBC
and Fox particularly but the second
thing is I think were work with CNS were
working harder and I've been in stations
where they got challenged and they
ignored it and now they're at the bottom
of the pile and CNN's determined not to
let that happen so they have they've
made some changes in programming they
made some changes in anchors and I think
that's good I think the competition is
competition is healthy and the other
thing has happened is the ratings are
not what they used to be the ratings
since September 11 September 11 are the
highest they've been since the Gulf War
but for that period in between the
ratings were not what they used to be
because the audience was some of the
audience was going to do with those
other networks so you know what you got
to fight harder you got to work harder
you've got to do better programming and
and present a better product and if you
don't you know
what's it like to be working for a
program where you get into four and a
half months of Chandra Levy every night
deadly deadly well ydn is the why do you
do it well I do it because I love
debating the issues I love studying
issues I love debating the issues I love
writing about the issues and I love
communicating about issues that's kind
of my whole life I've always done that
and crossfire I think is the pinnacle
opportunity to do that and I take that
little bit of bad because of the
tremendous good most of the time we are
debating good meaty serious substantive
issues that make a difference in
people's lives in this country but
sometimes we get in a rut Chandra Levy
was a runt Monica Lewinsky Russell was a
rut I wasn't there for LJ but that was
sort of another way when you have to do
it day in and day out partly because of
the competition you mentioned earlier
they're doing it that's what people want
to hear believe it or not and people may
say that they'd love to I'll talk about
something else you try it you'll find
out
so you just everyday we would try to
come up with some different angle on it
that meant you were not just simply
repeating yourself but it's it's I'd
rather get beat to a pulp on taxes or
beat to a pulp on healthcare you know or
beat to a pulp on missile defense than
have to do Gary Condit every night in
your book click story there we have time
sure yeah during Monica Lewinsky days
Pat Buchanan and I finally had had
enough one day a true story and we
decided we would protest we would do is
basically a sit-in boycott and on the
morning conference call where we decide
what we're going to talk about we said
we had talked about this ahead of time
and we announced we refused to do
another Monica Lewinsky show that night
we there were other important issues we
were going to do something else or else
they'd have to get two of the co-hosts
that night little rebellion from the
left and from the right they so what do
you want to do
are you ready for this Pat and I said
NATO expansion that was an important
issue but a probably we could have
chosen a better what we're both
interested in it we tubed that night it
was it was so bad so you did it we did
it we did NATO expansion and our ratings
went for this how much do you think the
audience understands how the process
works and that the numbers are there
every day and you can see what works and
what doesn't work
I haven't think they do I don't think
they do I think they tune in because
it's been on the other crossbar has been
going for over 19 years they tune in
because they like the format they like
the guests they like the fact that it's
lively and they hear both sides of an
issue but I don't think on any show
people understand how ratings work or
what goes into a show people a lot of
people think that crossfire is scripted
nothing scripted about it except the
opening minute where we set the topic
some people think it's taped it's almost
always live so I don't are there people
that won't come on the show by the way
oh sure yeah there are people who once
once people get to be a certain level
they perceive themselves too important
to to debate or to be in a debate
situation I had a member of Congress one
time John Kasich told me one time that
he he ended up doing crossfire by the
way that he did by first time I met him
he said he would never do crossfire
because when he was asked a question he
wanted five minutes uninterrupted to
answer that question and he knew we'd
never get on crossfire I don't know who
would give him that much time but but
that's the attitude Dick Gephardt did
our show when we were over at George
Washington University as a town meeting
but mr. Gebhardt won't come for a
regular crossfire hasn't you know that
there are others who just simply refuse
you we know and we know some people who
just will just won't do crossfire you
talk about bias and the liberal press
accusation in your book but you also
talk about the situation inside CNN
where you had a news
executives one of the new ones come I
was going to ask you whether or not that
was Walter Isaacson you don't mention
him by name in the book who came me and
isn't that who it was
you could ask me that but I'm not saying
I'm gonna answer it spinning me at the
moment came and met and talked about the
Tom DeLay thing Tom DeLay what's his
attitude about coming on CNN Oh Tom
DeLay hates CNN because he thinks CNN is
the Clinton news network
and and he's constantly complaining
about what he sees on CNN the coverage
on CNN and we not only refuse it's one
I'm sure he tries to talk other people
out of going onto CNN and he even his
office sent out a press release
attacking then the hiring of Tucker
Carlson as co-host of crossfire because
they didn't think he's conservative
enough I mean I can tell you
Tucker is conservative enough a debate
him every day so we ended up having this
what I thought was a sort of surreal
experience of sitting around as the CNN
staff in Washington DC and talked about
how we could modify or placate or may
come till they feel better about about
CNN which I mean I couldn't believe I
mean I I don't think it's our job to
please Tom DeLay or to please Dick
Gephardt but just to present the news
and I I must tell you even with my
liberal bias I think CNN is pretty much
right down the middle I mean as I've
mentioned in the book I'm never on CNN
unless I've got a conservative sitting
alongside of me I think they're they're
very very careful about providing both
sides of you both sides of a point of
view and so I thought it was sort of a
waste of time and maybe we should have
taken as a badge of honor if Tom DeLay
didn't think we were always spouting the
party line did you say anything at the
time I actually did not I
others did I bit my tongue what would
they say well I mean it's
it is it really that important to try to
please Tom DeLay I mean is that is is
that really something we ought to be be
concerned about now in your book you and
you even admitted in a US News and World
Report article some time ago that you
might not have any friends left in town
who did you criticize in here or who did
you spotlight that you were closest to
that worried you it's that's well the
book I'm an equal opportunity offender
you cannot talk about spin I would not
be honest if I talked about spin and
suggested that only conservatives spin
all politicians been liberal spin and
Democrats spent and in talking about
Democrats that's been I certainly
mentioned President Clinton whom I'm
close to Al Gore whom I'm close to
Hillary Rodham Clinton senator Clinton
whom I'm close to there may be there may
be some others I've heard I'm Tom
Daschle's on the example of his bin is
on the back cover and on the Republican
side I talk about Mary Matalin who's a
good friend as well but I don't mind
identifying than the spinners because a
point I make over and over again in the
book is that spin is not bad I mean
unless spin is way over the line and
someone is just lying and deceiving and
about some very important issue then I
think spin is just it's in our personal
life or in our professional life it's
how we survive and how we put ourselves
in the best possible light and and
everybody does it but some do it better
than others you did some history along
with the spinning presidential history
you also talked about HL Mencken you
said he was a straight straight shooter
among the journalists yeah i mean i
Menken bothers me a lot because of his a
very biased person i mean stuff he said
about jews and about women about
minorities pretty troubling but at the
same time i think i mean when it came to
to calling it calling it like it is he
was he was a straight shooter
i also talked about Mike Royko
great great columnist and as you may
remember as I mentioned in the book and
he was told that he had to come to
Washington if he really wanted to cast a
long shadow and he said I never I can
cast a fly rod but I don't care about
casting a long shadow did Abraham
Lincoln spent Abraham Lincoln certainly
certainly spun yeah well he spun that he
wasn't that he thought the Constitution
was perfect and he would not never do
anything to change it and he ended up
offering three amendments to the
Constitution he meant with Franklin
Roosevelt I mean Franklin Roosevelt the
whole that the fact that he he spun
himself as a vigorous healthy robust
president leading the country when in
fact he couldn't walk he called that his
splendid deception which i think is a
marvelous phrase for spin Richard Nixon
Richard Nixon was the worst of all
though I think the worst president and
and I think the worst spinner that
Watergate had by the way Richard Reeves
new book President Nixon is phenomenal
book I wish I had that book had been out
before I wrote this book as I would have
put more examples of Nixon spinning in
this book but the whole idea that
Watergate was a second-rate burglary
thought up by other people that he knew
nothing about when in fact he cooked up
the entire operation in the White House
and ran the entire operation out of the
White House he's won a really went over
the line and lied some I said he finally
finally got caught George Bush the
president I think I think the biggest
spin about President Bush is that he's
really running the country I mean I
think I think Vice President Cheney his
his doing more to set the direction for
the country and to manage the White
House and to direct the war effort and
to direct the foreign policy but the
White House has has managed to spin that
President Bush is the CEO who just
delegates all of this and I think
they've reinforced the spin they had for
a long time certainly by keeping vice
trainee in an undisclosed location in a
bunker somewhere that we're now this
will be an easy one for you not to spin
of all the conservatives that sit across
the table from you which one's your
favorite I have to spin that I and we're
gonna listen very carefully to what you
said listen I will I enjoy taking them
all on I have to tell you I think Pat
Buchanan is the best debater bar none
that I've ever been up against but Bob
Novak is close behind John Sununu very
smart Mary Matalin very sharp and Tucker
Carlson as good as all the rest who had
the best chemistry with sitting right
there on the set forget the the content
where it just the show flows easier me
maybe over the years Mary Madeline but
but no problem with any of them I mean I
do really like them I like working with
them I like them personally and we're
good friends before we run out of time
yeah you met your wife where I met Carol
in San Francisco in 1968 working for
Eugene McCarthy you have children mark
and David two sons Mark lives in Hood
River Oregon he's a nurse and nurse
practitioner works at La clinica in Hood
River Oregon and David is in graduate
school at the University of Davis and
works at the Point Reyes National
Seashore point raise California bill
press we're out of time this is what the
cover of the book looks like it's called
spin this bill press of crossfire CNN
thank you for joining us great to be
here Brian thank you